The biggest lie from gurus right now is
that AI makes things easy. It doesn't.
It makes things mediocre. And if you
want AI to make things really
incredible, then you have to learn the
skill of AI, like prompting and custom
bots, feeding it the right information.
And that is a skill set in itself. So,
if you want to get really good at
something like sales or copywriting or
anything, stop trying to start with AI
and actually start with the fundamentals
of the skill you're trying to get
really, really good at and then inject
AI into it later or never if you don't
want to. But don't believe the lie that
everything is easy and you can make 10K
a month instantly [music] and businesses
are begging for your mediocre AI emails.
It doesn't work like that.